- Hey I'm Constance Wu and I play Rachel.
- I'm Henry Golding , I play Nick Young.
- Hi, I'm Gemma Chan and I play Astrid.
- I'm Michelle Yeoh and
I play Eleanor Young.
- We are going to be doing a quiz
to figure out what character we should be.
- Yeah, we should've been.
- Alright, so pick a
delicious Singaporean dessert.
Do you know all of them?
- I've tried like three of them.
- Our options here are Pandan cake.
- [Both] Cheng Tng, Ice Kachang.
- Chendol, Tissue prata, Kueh.
- Chendol.
- Which one of these have you had?
I've had most of them.
- I have had none of them.
I would think I would should this Chendol.
- The Chendol.
- Because it looks like hung doa,
which is, you know, a thing I had.
And what do you choose?
- I'm gonna go for Pandan cake.
- I've gotta say Pandan cake,
which is like, it's like eating a cloud.
A soft, fluffy, delicious cloud.
- That shaved ice, Ice Kachang.
That's very, very popular.
- You're on vacation.
Which of the following would you
most likely be found doing?
- Parasailing, snorkeling,
reading, sightseeing,
eating everything and sleeping.
- I've never para sailed.
- It's boring.
- Thank you my friend.
- Sightseeing.
You gotta go out and explore
the city for me, for sure.
- I want to sightsee, but I also want
to snorkel if the water
is beautiful, right.
- It's the eating.
It's definitely the eating.
- I'm gonna go snorkeling.
- Snorkeling.
Cause I like fish.
- Choose a glamorous outfit.
- A suit.
- A suit, but I going to that one.
- Oh really?
- Oh yeah, I like.
- Would you like to wear a suit for a day?
- You know what, I would,
but none of these are double
breasted, which I'm into.
I think it's like retro cool, manly.
- I'm gonna for the summery suit.
- You know what, I've been
really into pink lately.
You know that.
- Uh-huh.
- So guess...
- The glittery pink or the more...
- Not that's purple.
The glittery one is not, no.
- I'm gonna go for number four.
I like a light suit.
- What's the most important trait
you look for in a best friend?
So a sense of humor, reliable, honest.
A little bit weird.
Good listener and generous.
- All of the above.
- All of the above, surely.
- Can't have one without the other, right?
- Reliable for me.
- Reliable.
- Best friend.
- [Both] You can only choose one.
- I'm gonna say reliable as well.
- I was gonna say
obviously sense of humor,
but than I saw a little bit
weird and I'm like, yeah.
A little bit weird.
- Which emoji really speaks to you?
Okay, oh yeah.
You going for the kiss?
- Oh you don't have the one
with the glasses that's my usual.
- Oh, the one with that's cursing.
That's me no doubt about it.
- I'm the one with the
teeth and the glasses.
That's my guy.
- I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck.
It's too, too tough.
I'm gonna say probably
the blasphemous one.
The swearing.
- Blowing a kiss.
- Finally pick a place
to buy your second home.
- New York City, Singapore,
London, Hong Kong, Taiwan or Sydney.
- Oh my gosh.
Sydney.
- Half of my friends
live in New York City,
because I lived there for a long time.
So...
- New York.
- I'm gonna have to go with New York City.
(laughing)
- I'm gonna choose New York.
- That's your friend.
(laughing)
- That's brilliant.
Ah yes.
- Ah.
- Mom.
- Oh God, wow.
I got Araminta Lee.
- I got Bernard Tai?
How did I get Bernard Tai?
- You get along with people who
go above and beyond to show kindness,
but you also really value your
independence and strength.
- Totally the opposite of myself.
- I think you should do jazz
hands while your reading this.
- You're someone who goes above and beyond
the call of duty to show your
appreciation to your friends.
Best of all, you're not
afraid to try new things
and seek adventures in new places.
- Like BuzzFeed quizzes that tell
you who you really are in your soul.
- I just...
- Realize so much about myself.
- Just accept it.
- I'm a Senoya.
I'll accept that.
- Someone who is earnest,
loyal and honest,
but if someone crosses
you prepare for the worst.
- Dun, dun, dun, dun.
- Sort of terrifying.
- Silly, friendly and down
for any kind of adventure.
You are the lovely Araminta.
- A brilliant. That's
a think that she says.
- You're a real social butterfly.
Okay, stop.
You are the type of person who warmly
welcomes new friends into your circle,
because you radiate kindness.
I would love to be Senoya.
- Jimmy I love you man, but...
- But he don't wanna be you. (laughs)
We love you, but he doesn't wanna be ya.
And Senoya, I love you and I wanna be you.
And I got you.